president biden is not talking about
afghanistan and has not for several days
today the president surveyed some of the
damage from last week's weather disaster
in the northeast a disaster he blames on
climate change
a whole segment
of our population denying this thing
called climate change right right
but i really mean it
sometimes
my mother used to say if everything bad
something good will come if you look
hard enough for it
well i think we've all seen
even the climate skeptics are seeing
that this really does matter
skeptics of the president's afghanistan
policy are fighting to keep the public
pressure on the administration to get
americans out of there white house
correspondent peter ducey shows us
tonight
if the taliban isn't letting americans
leave afghanistan does the white house
think that counts as a hostage situation
no that is not what we would
characterize it as
those were points that was those were
comments made by a republican
congressman this weekend the democratic
senate leader chuck schumer says the
americans all of whom wanted to come out
have come out praise god but that's not
true republican senator ben sasse says
americans are still trapped behind
taliban lines the biden administration
is still refusing to disclose how many
of our people they left behind and the
state department keeps talking about how
they really hope the taliban will live
up to their commitments pathetic the
international community is watching to
see
if the taliban will live up to their
commitments
some democrats are more than mad at the
biden white house senator richard
blumenthal says i've been deeply
frustrated even furious at our
government's delay and inaction and
senator tom cotton fears the
administration is negotiating with the
taliban i worry that they'll grant those
concessions because they simply want
afghanistan off the front pages the
taliban want their new government
recognized by other countries
that's a long way off
that's a long way off between now and
then the president is asking congress
for cash to help resettle afghans who
fled the taliban six point four billion
dollars to start do you plan to meet the
efficant refugees
so i plan to meet them well they're all
over they're all over the country and
i'll be soon i'll be sure i'll be seeing
some of them the white house is moving
on to other things president biden again
toured damage from a storm that killed
at least 60 people
every part of the country is getting hit
by extreme weather and vice president
harris is hoping to help gavin newsom
avoid a recall tweeting california
voting is underway
they're also counting votes in congress
for a three and a half trillion dollar
budget filled to the brim with
progressive
on
priorities
mr president i get questions yep is the
sun's gonna come out tomorrow
and you heard a little bit of it off the
top there but the president's trip to
new jersey and new york to help people
that just lost everything very quickly
turned political he went so far as to
suggest or to claim that his domestic
build back better agenda is so climate
change focused that if another storm
like ida was to pass through there would
be no damage mike peter ducey live on
the north lawn peter thanks a lot